una agresión por la que revisará a fondo
la relación con españa así describió
nicolás maduró la visita de la ministra
de exteriores española arantxa gonzález
laia a la ciudad colombiana de cúcuta
principal puerta de llegada de
inmigrantes venezolanos que huyen de la
crisis económica en su país esto después
de que el gobierno venezolano expulsar a
la embajadora de la unión europea
la portuguesa isabel brillante en
respuesta a las sanciones impuestas por
el bloque contra diputados y
funcionarios del gobierno de maduro si
los europeos como estado miembro quieren
reconstruir los puentes con venezuela
saben que siempre nuestro gobierno el
gobierno bolivariano y el estado
venezolano me atrevo a hablar por el
estado venezolano tenderán sus brazos y
sus manos para que efectivamente podamos
hacerlo pero exigimos respeto exigimos
respeto a nuestra constitución nuestras
leyes ya las leyes internacionales la
canciller española expreso que estas
acciones de venezuela no ayudan a
resolver la crisis romper puentes
cortar diálogos y expulsar a nuestros
diplomáticos no ayuda en esa labor de
diálogo yo
modestamente en nuestro país españa
modestamente apuesta por el diálogo para
solucionar también el conflicto político
que existe en venezuela la visita se
encuadra en un viaje de gonzález lay a
colombia en la que ha mostrado el apoyo
de españa el país tras la creación del
estatuto temporal de protección para los
al menos un millón 748 mil migrantes
venezolanos que hay en colombia por su
parte el presidente venezolano nicolás
maduro acusó el sábado al presidente
colombiano de usar a los inmigrantes
para justificar los recursos que
solicita organismos internacionales y
que según él terminan en las mafias